je viens d'un pays où il n'y avait plus
de futur et où j'ai passé 25 années à
essayer de construire un cheminement de
reconversion ce pays petit pays
ça s'appelle le pays minier dans le pas
de calais connaissez peut-être le pas de
calais parce que quand on passe à la
télé les gens pensent qu'on parle pas
français
alors on nous met des sous titrages
quand les journalistes font une image
il cherchait un enfant dont le nez coule
et un carreau cassé dans ma commune le
sol abaissée de 15 mètres à peu près à
cause des affaissements miniers c'est à
dire qu'on a tiré le matériau en dessous
alors c'est quand même assez surprenant
parce que les rivières et le cool en
sens inverse et les réseaux d'eau sont
fracturées et les hommes mouraient à 40
ans 50 ans de la silicose c'était normal
de donner sa vie pour élever ses enfants
c'était la règle mon un de mes grand
oncle est mort à 34 ans de la silicose
cette maladie qui ronge les poumons
voilà c'était assez terrible et les
oiseaux étaient partis je vous parle les
oiseaux parce qu'un oiseau est revenu et
qu'il a tout changé
comment il est revenu cet oiseau oui
j'oubliais de dire quand même très
important
les richesses il y en a eu énormément
produite énormément mais elles sont
partis ailleurs
et nous moi en tant qu'élu on doit faire
face à toutes les pollutions à toutes
les reconstructions
mais rassurez vous l'oiseau est revenu
pourquoi l'oiseau est revenu
figurez-vous que chez nous à l'arrière
quelques montagnes noires montagne noire
on appelle ça des terry letairis c'est
ce qui a été extrait au fond jusqu'à
moins 1000 m dans ma commune
c'est du schiste de la pierre la
poutrelle
on appelle ça des crassiers des tas de
déchets le quoi et puis parce que je
suis ornithologues un jour j'observe à
traquer moteur à jos pas vous demander
qui s'y connaît le traquet motteux peut
être un ou deux enfin si vous le voyez
vous le reconnaîtrez il a un petit
croupion blanc adorable étincelant et
c'est un oiseau qui vit en montagne il a
besoin de pierre pour nicher sous les la
plus alpine chez vous allez faire du gr
vous enverrez et il vit dans les
alpilles en scandinavie et cet oiseau
qui remontait en migration prénuptiale
il a trouvé avec les terry un milieu qui
lui convenait et mon terrier héberger un
oiseau rare et ça a complètement changé
mon regard sur les terrils je voyais
depuis que j'étais tout petit j'allais à
l'école comme ces montagnes qui étaient
là qui faisait partie du paysage
je pensais qu'il y en avait partout et
se terry donc qui hébergeait cet oiseau
rare
ça a commencé à me faire changer de
lunettes sur lui et j'ai rencontré des
amis j'ai rencontré fin des gens qui
sont devenus des amis
j'ai rencontré des urbanistes par
exemple qui disaient qu'ils avaient eux
aussi avaient échangé leurs lunettes et
qui disait mail et terry dans ce pays
plat du nord c'est sont nos seuls
repères ce sont nos beffroi qui
structurent le territoire
j'ai rencontré des artistes qui sont
devenus des amis et qui me disait mais
regarde ces triangles merveilleux qui
monte au ciel tout noir tous purent un
petit cheminement mais c'est vrai que
c'était beau j'ai rencontré des mineurs
bien sûr qu'ils disaient les terry s'est
passé dans nos mains il s'est plaint de
sueur c'est plein de notre sens est une
c'est terry et donc avec ces pionniers
qui avions changé de lunettes
on a décidé de s'organiser on a décidé
de créer une association qui s'appelle
la chaîne des terrils parce qu'on en
avait marre quand plus qu'on nous impose
au chômage on nous dise qu'on soit pas
beau et qu'on nous dise qu'il fallait se
renier parce qu'à l'époque tout le monde
disait il faut raser tout ça un jour un
journalisme dit france 3 j'étais tout
jeune ni monsieur caron je ne devrais
pas vous interviewez j'ai vu monsieur
tut qui m'a dit mais arrêtez de donner
la parole à ce mec il est dangereux
nous on veut ressembler à tout le monde
et c'était terrible cette volonté de
négation alors que 29 nationalités venus
travailler chez nous quand on avait un
système de valeurs extraordinaires que
la vie dans les cités minières étaient
mille fois plus joyeuse et agréable mais
ce bassin minier recelait de plein de
systèmes de valeurs donc on s'est
organisé et puis quand la dernière
gaillette est remontée ce que vous savez
ce que c'est une gaillette
pas sûr non plus un morceau de charbon
petit un moyen un gros un gros c'est le
jackpot
donc quand on a remonté la dernière
gaillette du terril de oignies de la
fosse de oignies pardon france 3
toujours à organiser un débat un débat
entre le grand patron de l' empire des
houillères un monsieur qui est plein de
diplôme il faisait son job était là pour
gagner faire gagner des sous à sa boîte
et pour lui les terry c'était des tas de
matériaux ça se vendait c'était des
dollars
on disait pas encore d euros et moi
j'étais en face parce que j'étais un peu
le représentant du monde qui va venir
vous savez pas quoi mais j'avais créé la
chaîne des terrils on avait un regard on
essayait de commencer à imaginer ce que
pourrait être l'avenir
donc on a fait ce débat parce que c'est
j'étais quand même un peu tétanisé
devant ce monsieur doctoresse je ne sais
quoi mais moi j'étais pas tout seul
j'étais pas tout seul parce que j'avais
mon arrière grand père avec moi qui
avait été déléguée mineurs au fond de la
mine meneurs de grève en 1900 qui avait
appelé ses enfants
rosa juvénal danton ferrer églantine et
vos grands-pères voltaire juvénal et
danton ont été garde du corps de léon
blum sont venus à paris j'étais pas tout
seul parce que j'avais le trac et motos
avec moi j'avais la nature j'avais plein
de culot bref on a commencé à
s'organiser pour se dire on va pas se
laisser faire on va passer c'est prendre
nos séries et on a gagné
le ministère de le ministre de
l'industrie 1992 à imposer à
charbonnages de france
l'institution par excellence une
partition entre les québec qu'on allait
garder pour la nature les québécois à
l'égard des pour leurs fonctions
symboliques comme par exemple le territ
renard a donné que zola avait décrit
dans germinal saint-jérôme inhalent vous
l'avez lu normalement et puis les terry
quand même quelques quelques terribles
pour les matériaux et à partir de là on
a commencé à retrouver un peu de dignité
et de fierté
tout simplement on on n'avait pas réglé
nos problèmes mais on sait on savait
qu'ils avaient de la valeur que tout ça
c'était fragile qu'il fallait
s'organiser et on a commencé à avoir un
certain nombre de premiers résultats
j'ai créé une école de parapente
alors ça tf1 adoré
dl rose fluo sur fonds ppte et riz pour
la télé c'est du bonheur antenne 2 aussi
on disait antenne 2 on a travaillé sur
notre trajectoire
qu'est ce qui nous fonde et et on l'a
pris par le culturel
on a organisé des sons lumières et des
mines des mineurs qui jouaient leur
propre rôle
ils sont une lumière participatif on a
fait du land art sur les terrains
pendant qu'ici christo emballe et le
pont neuf
nous on faisait le fuji yama entre temps
j'ai été élu au conseil régional parce
que les gens avaient dû estimer que tous
avaient de l'importance de ces combats
là puis je suis devenu élu local
et là j'ai eu à m'occuper de l'urbanisme
du plan d'occupation des sols et très
vite il m'est apparu que on ne pourrait
pas faire un plan d'occupation des sols
sans un vrai projet de ville or nous on
avait plus de ville on avait plus de
futur comme au far west
quand on a quitté les mines d'or et que
tout est resté en l'état
mais comment voulez-vous où voulez vous
mettre un million de personnes
un petit peu à dunkerque un petit peu au
havre qui peut paris c'était pas
possible et donc très vite il m'est
apparu qu'on ne pourrait faire de
véritables plans d'occupation des sols
là où on mettrait l'agriculture l'eau
mais très les usines là où on pourrait
construire on ne pourrait le faire que
sur un vrai projet de ville
villenouvelle dans notre représentation
et que ça ne pourrait être qu'une oeuvre
collective que ça pouvait pas être à
dire d'expert
c'est pas un expert qui pouvait même si
on a besoin des experts qui pouvait nous
dire notre futur
c'était pas les élus même si on a besoin
des élus j'en fais partie ils ont la
légitimité
ça ne pouvait se faire que dans un
processus collectif et c'est comme ça
qu'on a un style et le raisonnement le
virus d'habitants acteurs de mettre les
gens en situation de commencer à
comprendre nuire la ville et nos
premiers nos premières expérimentations
sont des coulées de là on avait une eau
absolument catastrophique
100 mg de nitrates le double de la norme
alors dans le plan d'occupation des sols
et dans nos actions de ville il faudrait
être draconiens sur la protection de la
ressource en eau on était avec des
maisons des mines où on avait charbon
gratuit qui étaient des passoires alors
l'éco construction et la réhabilitation
thermique devenez absolument stratégique
et c'est comme ça que nos premières
expérimentations sont sortis et que
progressivement a commencé à se dessiner
une vision une vision d'un nouveau
modèle de développement mais avec des
signaux faibles
un peu comme on dirait aujourd'hui on
sort de la société du gaspillage on voit
bien que le nouveau modèle de
développement sera plutôt sur la
sobriété le recyclage en prenant
contre-pied de nos histoires et donc ce
nouveau modèle de développement qui
n'étaient pas encore apparus mais dont
on touché par petits bouts ce qui
pourrait devenir progressivement à nous
qui avions vu l'homme et la nature
martyrisé on devait en même temps
construire la transition et c'est très
compliqué d'emmener une communauté un
collectif est de dire on va changer de
monde mais on sait pas vers quel monde
on vit
et c'est pour ça qu'on a énormément
travaillé les questions de résilience
on a même travaillé que des psychologues
pour comprendre comment ça fonctionne et
cette capacité à réagir après un choc
qui nous avait complètement déstructuré
progressivement la confiance et
réinstaller par la qualité des
collectifs qu'on avait monté par le
travail qu'on faisait ensemble par le
fait qu ont posé des actes sur la façon
de reconquérir notre espace et puis j'ai
beaucoup insisté sur cette idée qu'il
fallait libérer les initiatives on
sortait d'une société encadrés par le
système des houillères
le problème c'est que quand vous devez
inventer un monde
il faut faire des innovations et une
innovation c'est une désobéissance qui a
réussi mais c'est d'abord une
désobéissance et donc on a travaillé la
question du droit à l'erreur parce que
si vous n'avez jamais le droit de vous
tromper
alors moi je vous garantis que jamais
vous ne ferez quelque chose
vous si vous avez des enfants et que
voulaient pister en permanence et que
vous les empêchez de transgresser un
petit peu alors ce sera difficile donc
on a travaillé ces questions là on a
multiplié les processus de prise
d'initiative et on est progressivement
devenue une ville pilote du
développement durable progressivement
d'abord on a fait apparaître
on a essayé de travailler la question de
la vision et du rêve parce que c'est
terrible période dans laquelle on est
aujourd'hui nous c'était il ya 25 ans
collectivement aller à l'échelle
mondiale où on en est aujourd'hui
il est où le rêve la vision qui permet
de mobiliser des collectifs qui permet
de se mettre en mouvement
a beaucoup d'égards nos actions
politiques sont des actions de
boutiquiers on change des petits bouts
de trucs mais on n'a pas véritablement
de perspectives on avait besoin de cette
vision et de ce rêve mais un rêve c'est
une étoile qui brille qui vous donne
envie
si vous n'avez pas les petits cailloux
blancs qui mène à l'est à l'étoile alors
vous restez dans la sidération vous en
avez envie de cette étoile mais vous ne
savez pas comment vous mettre en
mouvement et c'est pour ça qu'on a
travaillé sur toute une série de signaux
symbolique l'église en est un exemple
réglisse extraordinaire parce que c'est
l'idée qu'on va mettre les énergies
renouvelables dans la ville du charbon
qui est quand même un petit coup de pied
un petit pied de nez à l'histoire et
petite anecdote on a sans arrêt des
maires des communautés de communes qui
viennent nous visiter qu'ils menaient
alors mais comment parce que c'est la
première de france
mais comment vous avez réussi à faire
cette église en capteurs photovoltaïques
et me pose des questions sur la
charpente sur le prix de rachat par edf
sur la technologie en silicium amorphe
ou pas et quand ils vont s'en aller
juste avant de partir je ne me voir à
voix plus basse puis me disent mais
comment ça s'est passé avec le curé
parce que la vraie question c'est celle
là comment va réagir la communauté
catholique et moi j'ai toujours la
lettre de l'évêque sur moi quand ils
viennent je sais qu'ils vont me poser
cette question et je leur montre la
lettre de l'évêque monseigneur jachère
c'est ça vous intéresse qui nous a
félicités sur le fait que cette église
participer l'avancée du monde d'ailleurs
pour la venue du kop 21 dans notre
commune qu en prévision d'ici le mois de
décembre on a invité le pape
c'est vous dire je sais pas s'il va
venir c'est vous dire mais c'est
merveilleux de pouvoir travailler avec
la communauté catholique et avec toutes
les communautés dans la façon de
construire progressivement la ville donc
l'église c'est un petit caillou blanc
et puis enfin besoin de processus
collaboratif n'ont pas de démocratie
participative au sens où on va faire des
réunions publiques pour vous demander ce
que vous voulez ça s'appelle les cahiers
de doléances et ses monstrueuses ça
pourquoi c'est monstrueux parce que vous
dites
le maire m'a invité je vais aller lui
dire je veux que dis-je
j'exige je paye des impôts c'est quand
même bien normal que j'exige alors vous
me permettrez la formule participation
sans responsabilisation égale pied
chaque mois
parce que si vous n'êtes que dans un
processus d'expression de la demande
c'est absolument monstrueux on consomme
de l'action publique comme on consomme à
auchan et donc tous nos processus
on était basé sur une logique de
responsabilisation des acteurs
nos résultats ont la développer le
solaire
on ne consomme plus un seul litre d'eau
potable depuis au moins dix ans pour les
usages de la ville
c'est compliqué pour veolia innovants
plus d'eau pour arroser notre terrain de
foot
on prend donc on prend de l'eau de pluie
tout simplement voilà et c'est juste du
bon sens pour la population
on a massivement généralisée l'éco
construction de la réhabilitation
thermique
on a aujourd'hui des gens qui payent on
m'a amené une facture 197 euros de
chauffage à l'année dans un t4 pour une
famille 2 adultes 2 enfants de rue à
côté au chauffage électrique c 2 1000
euros et les gens cela se caille dans
leur maison y a pas besoin de grands
baratin pour expliquer ce que c'est que
le développement durable
on en parle à la sortie de l'école c'est
tout simple
c'est tout simple c'est des signaux
concrets on a multiplié par deux le
nombre d'associations
on a renforcé les circuits courts qu'on
a eu un retour des commerces parce que
l'image de la commune avec
considérablement changé qu'elle devenait
attractive
on a créé 350 emplois dixit l'insee on a
transformé notre grand site minier en
une véritable cité scientifique pôle
d'excellence sur les éco activités pôle
de compétitivité sur l'économie
circulaire et puis ce dont je suis le
plus fier car dans les yeux dans les
yeux c'est que parce que l'histoire des
mineurs vaut celle des rois
nous avons réussi à inscrire le bassin
minier au patrimoine mondial de
l'humanité
et ça
et ça c'est merveilleux c'est
merveilleux premier bassin est placé au
monde pour son sa contribution à
l'histoire de la planète pas seulement
l'histoire des châteaux et des
cathédrales
évidemment ça participe et de notre
processus de recherche de dignité et de
fierté
bien sûr que l'unesco ramène des
touristes mais nous c'est pas pour ça
qu'on l'a fait c'est une thérapie pour
nous d'être inscrit à l'unesco
ceci dit s'il ya des touristes qui
viennent on les accueille et si ça peut
vous donner envie de venir découvrir le
traquet motteux ce sera avec plaisir
deux derniers résultats aux élections
ont été réélus et 82,1 % des voix le
plus gros score du nord pas de calais
alors que je suis une erreur de
l'histoire
je m'en excuse un écolo au pays des
gueules noires
vous avez déjà vu ça vous c'est pas
possible cette affaire donc c'est qu'un
peu un coup de tonnerre sur cette idée
que la reprise en main de son destin par
une population générer des effets
absolument magique de qualité de notre
communauté
et puis la consécration c'est que
l'ademe est venu pour nous labellisés
comme son premier démonstrateur en
france sur le développement durable
premier démonstrateur sociétale qu'est
ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire qu'on
n'arrivera pas à changer de modèle sans
l'application de chacun et pour chacun
soit impliqué alors l'ensemble des
petites actions content et quand vous
vous brossez les dents et que vous
fermez l'eau du rabbit du robinet vous
contribuez à sauver la planète mais ça
ne suffit pas
ça ne suffit pas si on n'a pas des
changements beaucoup plus globaux
sociétaux si on ne réagit kull pas en
sens bhl les questions économiques
sociales et environnementales qu'on
continue à garder un certain modèle
économique et à essayer d'éviter les
fuites environnementales et les dégâts
sur l'homme
si on ne pense pas l'ensemble comme un
modèle de développement
harmonieux où l'homme et la nature ne
sont plus des variables d'ajustement
alors on n'y arrivera pas c'est ça la
période dans laquelle on est et c'est ça
que nous on a essayé de faire par toute
une série de choses hyper chiant ce dont
je vais pas vous parler la
transversalité les processus de
coopération
tout ça c'est de la technique on s'en
fout mais l'idée c'est de se dire qu'il
faut qu'on arrive à réorienter autrement
notre modèle de développement est de ce
point de vue là agir dans une ville
c'est merveilleux pourquoi ça marche ça
a marché parce que conseiller en
trajectoire
ça a marché parce qu'on a un projet
collectif qui implique
ça a marché parce qu'on ose et qu on
s'est affronté un certain nombre de
pensée unique
je pourrais faire au moins trois tours
là dessus sur les pensées uniques et
parce qu'on a toujours toujours essayé
d'entrer par le réel et par le concret
parce que ça c'est absolument faux
fondamental pour que les gens puissent
rentrer dans le dispositif
alors voilà nous on était dans le
gouffre pas au bord du gouffre dans le
gouffre dans le gouffre patrick viveret
a dit l'humanité a rendez vous avec elle
même au 21ème siècle
alors moi je vous dis re donnons du sens
remettons de la mise en responsabilité
et vous verrez qu'on peut reprendre
prises on avait de la chance
paradoxalement on n'est pas le choix il
ya 25 ans on avait l'épée dans les reins
on n'avait pas le choix c'était notre
chance on est parti de nos valeurs
l'homme et la nature ne sont pas des
variables d'ajustement
on a choisi un nouveau regard ça nous a
changés nous mêmes on a retrouvé la
confiance de la vision une place pour
chacun dans la l'effort collectif
d'inventer un nouveau modèle
et puis surtout on a retrouvé du désir
du désir de développement durable parce
que si le développement durable c'est
qu'une addition une admission de
contraintes et des grands discours de
morale jamais le développement durable
ne s'imposera alors que si on se remet
en perspective et de considérer que dire
bonjour à son voisin plutôt que de lui
faire la gueule ou faire une haie de
trois mètres de haut aimer la nature et
reprendre en main nous mêmes notre
destin c'est tout simplement joyeux ça
nous redonne please est donc aujourd'hui
tout n'est pas réglé à loos en gohelle
bien entendu loin s'en faut
on est à notre petite échelle on est en
train de travailler au changement
d'échelle chaque histoire est unique
la nôtre est unique chacune d'entre vous
êtes unique mais souvenez vous si vous
changez de regard sur les choses
alors vous pourrez soulever des
montagnes
pas seulement des terry merci